[Musique]
bon on est tous sur Internet on veut
tous naviguer de façon sécuritaire
est-ce que les VPN sont la grande
solution tel qu'on nous le dit
vous savez c'est quoi un réseau VPN un
réseau VPN oui est-ce que s'il y a une
question de sécurité selon vous c'est
exactement ce qui te permet justement
d'entrer dans l'entreprise qu'est-ce que
vous comprenez du fonctionnement
je sais même pas non c'est la sécurité
surtout au niveau de protéger vos
données vous leur faites confiance
est-ce que vous croyez que c'est
véritablement sécuritaire est-ce que
vous faites confiance entièrement et
totalement à ce système VPN
il doit avoir des failles c'est pas
blindé mais ça te cache de ton aisep tu
vois pas ce qu'ils font en arrière là
mais tu le sais jamais dire
vous le savez à l'heure du numérique
nous donner et nous informations
personnelles sont plus que jamais
exposées s'aventurer sur le Web requiert
de plus en plus de prudence de vigilance
c'est donc tout à fait normal qu'on se
fasse offrir toutes sortes de moyens et
de services pour se protéger parmi cette
offre abondante la connexion via VPN à
grands coups de marketing les
entreprises qui vendent ce type de
connexion promettent de faire passer
votre cyber sécurité à un niveau
supérieur alors qu'en est-il mirage
poudre aux yeux ou la solution qu'il
vous faut
Nicolas il fallait qu'on en parle au
décrypteur un jour ou l'autre les fameux
VPN les réseaux VPN dont on parle
beaucoup dans des publicités à la
télévision bien entendu mais aussi sur
le web il y a des youtubeurs qui en font
au mention dans des vidéos moussant
l'idée des grands mérites que nous
apporterait ses réseaux VPN mais
allons-y concrètement la dis-nous les
VPN qu'est-ce que ça peut faire mais
avant d'expliquer ce que ça peut faire
définition
network ou réseau virtuel privé
essentiellement ce que ça fait c'est que
ça peut crypter nos données navigation
Internet pour les faire passer par un
serveur alternatif ou on pourrait même
dire par un tuyau alternatif donc pour
transitent pas bon ben pour qu'il soit
pas vu par nos fournisseurs internet ou
même les administrateurs des réseaux
publics auxquels on se connecte donc si
on est dans un café par exemple si on
veut pas les administrateurs du réseau
de ce café là voient les sites qu'on est
en train de visiter on peut servir d'un
VPN et encore si on veut pas que nos
fournisseurs internet le voient on peut
utiliser un VPN ça c'est un des usages
qui comprend à faire concrètement ça
fonctionne un autre usage c'est de faire
comme si qu'on était dans un autre pays
donc quand on active un VPN on a une
nouvelle adresse IP et on est perçu
comme étant dans un autre pays par les
serveurs auquel on se connecte donc par
exemple si je veux aller écouter une
émission qui est seulement disponible
sur Netflix en France c'est tout simple
je pars mon VPN je dis que je suis en
France ça va faire comme si je suis en
france je peux me connecter à Netflix et
je peux aller écouter des émissions qui
sont seulement diffusées en France ça
permet de contourner la géolocalisation
de certains contenus
on peut être un peu n'importe où exact
c'est exactement ça c'est très utile
pour ça à l'air justement il y a toutes
sortes d'émissions exclusives
sur Netflix sur sur toutes ces
plateformes là et finalement dans la
même dans le même ordre d'idée
finalement où on peut changer de pays
mais si on est dans un pays où
l'Internet est censuré où on est par
exemple en Russie après l'invasion en
Ukraine le gouvernement russe bloqué
toutes sortes de sites web bloquer
l'accès aux réseaux sociaux mais l'usage
VPN à ce moment-là Russie a augmenté
lors d'une manière fulgurante pour ça
aussi un VPN c'est très utile donc voilà
trois cas d'usage très concrets au plus
anciens la Russie mais on peut aussi
évoquer l'Iran actuellement en ce moment
le régime qui resserre les taux autour
de l'accès à Internet là-bas et le VPN
permet aux Iraniens de communiquer avec
le monde extérieur mais au-delà de ces
possibilités bien spécifiques on nous
vend souvent l'idée du VPN comme étant
une garantie ou une protection
nécessaire en matière de sécurité
personnelle en quoi c'est vrai ça ben
oui visiblement ce marketing là il
fonctionne il y a une récente étude qui
a été publiée aux Etats-Unis qui
montrent que 82% des utilisateurs de VPN
s'en servent pour se protéger de menaces
et que 86 % des utilisateurs ont
l'impression d'être plus en sécurité
alors c'est une impression d'abord avant
tout ou si la réalité de ce sentiment de
sécurité ben en bonne partie oui ce
n'est qu'une impression même si le
marketing nous ferait croire autrement
là parce que les VPN nous protègent pas
d'une très grande majorité des menaces
auxquelles on peut faire face quand on
navigue sur internet donc la plupart des
pirates des logiciels malveillants des
virus sur un VPN va pas nous protéger de
façon là et si on craint pour nos
données personnelles à nos données
sensibles comme un mot de passe ou
encore des informations bancaires un VPN
va pas les protéger non plus parce que
si on est pour se faire hameçonner un
VPN ça nous empêchera pas de se faire
entendre et on va tout de même soumettre
nos informations à quelqu'un de
malveillant par contre il y a une nuance
à tout ça il y a un type d'attaque bien
spécifique contre laquelle les VPN
peuvent nous protéger et c'est l'attaque
dite de l'homme au milieu donc la
fameuse personne qui va intercepter nos
communications dans un café sur un
réseau public ce n’attaque qui est de
plus en plus rare au fil des ans surtout
maintenant que les sites sont de mieux
en mieux sécurisés mais elle existe
encore le VPN pour ce type d'attaque
spécifique là oui peut nous protéger
mais la morale de l'histoire d'antiso
c'est que le marketing selon un expert à
qui j'ai parlé John Scott realton avec
tout ce marketing autour des VPN qui
donne l'impression que c'est un espèce
de solution magique là un mur étanche
pour la sécurité en ligne ben ça donne
des fausses impressions et en plus les
gens après ça ont un faux sentiment de
sécurité grâce à ce public là on
l'écoute votre confidentialité et votre
sécurité sur Internet c'est un peu comme
votre santé numérique bon c'est ce qui
se passe quand il y a du désinformation
sur des questions de santé les gens
souffrent et aujourd'hui
notre compréhension et notre réalité de
confidentialité et sécurité souffrent
puisqu'elle est tellement de mes
informations tellement de marketing de
mauvaise foi tellement de marketing
trompeur et ce qu'on voit aussi Nicolas
dans ce type de marketing c'est nous
vendre l'idée selon laquelle je sais pas
moi par exemple je suis une personne qui
veut qui veut pas être pisté par les
publicitaires ou les gouvernements
dans ces cas là le VPN ou les réseaux
VPN peuvent être utiles mais pour ce qui
est les publicités pas tellement c'est
vrai que bon un VPN nous donne une
nouvelle adresse IP quelle adresse IP
peut être utilisée pour nous pister par
des publicitaires mais publicitaires ont
toutes sortes d'autres moyens encore
plus sophistiqués de nos pister et le
VPN ne nous protège pas contre moyenne
donc il y a les fameux témoins de sites
web autrement nommé des cookies et sinon
il y a aussi les pixels espions qui sont
mis sur des sites qui peuvent également
nous pister si on est par exemple
connecté à notre compte média sociaux ou
à notre compte Google pendant qu'on sert
d'un VPN mais c'est contre là collègues
de données sur nous et on peut nous
pister de cette manière là aussi donc le
VPN encore là c'est pas une solution
magique sinon pour ce qui est de la
surveillance gouvernementale c'est vrai
ça peut rendre ça plus difficile tout à
fait par contre il y a un grand bémol à
ça parce que la plupart des VPN disent
qu'ils ne collecte pas les données de
navigation des utilisateurs mais il y a
eu plusieurs cas ou des gouvernements
ont fait des demandes légales à ses
compagnies là pour avoir les données
d'utilisateur les compagnies ont ensuite
obtempérer et elles avaient accès à des
données navigation donc même si les
compagnies font des garanties c'est pas
toujours vrai les compagnies sont très
opaques difficile d'avoir leur juste
là-dessus et la certaine qui comme
expressvpn par exemple en 2017 avait une
demande de gouvernement et comme de fait
il y avait aucune donnée navigation de
la personne concernée donc il y a des
cas oui où ça peut fonctionner mais
c'est loin de toujours fonctionner et
surtout ce qu'on fait en utilisant un
VPN c'est qu'on prend la confiance qu'on
accorde à notre fournisseur internet et
on déplace cette confiance là au
fournisseur de VPN et selon John Scott
realton il faudrait ni faire confiance
aux fournisseurs de services Internet ni
faire confiance au fournisseur de VPN
moi je n'ai ni confiance dans la
majorité des compagnies des VPN ni dans
mes fournisseurs d'Internet
cela présente un problème pour les
consommateurs mais c'est un problème qui
devrait être géré au niveau légal du
scrutin régulatoire etc des compagnies
mais en ce moment si vous voulez on est
dans un Wild West presque total tout le
monde veut votre data y compris certains
compagnies qui achètent maintenant des
VPN et on entendait monsieur Scott
realten parler des compagnies qui
possèdent les VPN ce qu'il faut noter
aussi à ce chapitre lost que ses
compagnies-là plusieurs d'entre elles
sont aussi propriétaires de sites web de
critiques de VPN propriétaire des sites
web d'actualité technologiques ce qui
fait en sorte que il y a plusieurs
experts qui ont soulevé des doutes sur
l'indépendance des critiques on peut
lire en ligne souvent de VPN donc il
faut vraiment faire attention à
l'information que je vous ai présenté
c'est difficile de savoir ce qu'on peut
croire ou non à cet effet-là et sinon je
dirais peut-être au public de consulter
des sites indépendants de protection de
consommateurs qui parlent de ces
produits là peut-être pour s'informer
plutôt que
des sites spécialisés